Now we talked about the need for
labels when you want to talk about MAC,
or multi-level security.
And we even said, well, user has
a certain label, file has another label.
And we have to say, we have to check,
if user with this label L1,
should he or she be able to access
the document that has label L2?
So we have to sort of
compare these labels.
So here, we're going to explore
how that comparison might work.
So let's just talk about labels of the
type that we discussed in the context
of the military intelligence community
and how they access information.
So, sensitivity, how sensitive data is.
We said that, we had those circles,
top-secret is the most sensitive,
secret, next level,
then classified, and unclassified.
We had restricted in the middle there,
but I'm just picking
these four examples.
So what does this greater than mean?
So we are saying that, these levels
are actually ordered totally.
And by total order, what we mean here
is that if I pick any two of these,
I can tell you which one is more
sensitive than the other one.
So TS is the most sensitive.
If you took TS and
any other of these levels,
then we know that this is higher, or
is greater than, the other level.
Similarly, secret is greater,
or higher, than classified.
So this greater really means it's
higher level of sensitivity.
And total order basically means,
when you pick any pair so
the relations and various kind of
orders that you can define for
the elements that are in a given set,
that's where it defines a relation.
So the total here means you pick
any two elements of this set,
and there is an order between them, so
one is always going to be more
sensitive than the other one.
Here we see that through this greater
than sign, symbol that we have.
We do know that labels have a level,
sensitivity level.
But they also have a compartment.
And we said compartments are sort of
sets of different topics or categories.
And how do you compare sets?
You take set S1 and S2.
S1 may be contained in S2,
S2 may be contained in S1, or
neither set may be
contained in the other one.
So if set S1 has some
elements that S2 doesn't, and
vice versa, then neither set
will be contained in the other.
So when you have sets, the way you
compare them is containment, or
subset, or
is one a subset of another one?
And we know that that
order is a partial order.
So total order is when,
pick any two, and
one always is greater than or
higher than the other.
When you talk about sets,
we know there are going to be
pairs of sets where neither
one contains the other one,
and they're not going to be ordered,
so that's called partial order.
So we'll explore this a little
bit more through examples.
But if a label is going to have two
parts, one part is totally ordered,
one part is ordered sometimes and
not comparable at other times, so
that's the partial order.
So when we talk about actually ordering
labels, we had to look into the label.
We have to look into
the sensitivity level.
What are the sensitivity levels?
If the labels that we're comparing is
L1 and L2, then we are to look at L1's
sensitivity level and L2's sensitivity
level and how they compare.
And then we're going to look at the
compartment of each one of those, and
then compare those compartments.
And by comparing both parts,
then we going to be able to
decide how to order the labels.